this guy who is most known as Florida
Joker dyed his hair purple and is trying
to sue Rockstar Games for using his
likeness in case you missed it in the
Grand Theft Auto 6 trailer this
character appeared alongside a montage
of a whole bunch of like famous viral
clips from people doing weird in
Florida and Florida Joker has demanded
$2 million from Rockstar Games for using
his likeness at all saying that if they
don't give him $2 million he will sue
them which he will definitely lose while
I would not at all be surprised if this
guy was was inspired by this guy it's
different enough none of the tattoos are
the same even if it was it's easy to
argue that it's parody I mean Lindsay
Lohan already tried to Sue rockar and
failed I don't think this guy is likely
to succeed